[Music]
grace in seattle washington i was just
in seattle this weekend what's up grace
oh hi john how are you doing good i tell
you what
i
seattle is one of the most beautiful
places i've ever we flew in last weekend
it is stunning how beautiful it is wow
yeah it's beautiful here
so what's up how can i help
um so first off i'm gonna say i have a
cold my voice is gonna be a little
funny
that's awesome cool
um but my question was i was wondering
if you had
any resources or tips on how to navigate
my relationship with my sister um she
has autism okay i was also wondering if
she'd help me process my childhood
growing up with her
that's a lot
um
so tell me about your sister
um
able to talk
yeah she's very mobile she's able to
talk she um graduated high school just a
few years later than she would normally
graduate
but she's very smart but she still has a
lot of like emotional issues i guess
sure
yeah and so what was it like growing up
um
when we were little kids it was really
good because we were very close we
shared a room
but then as i got into like middle
school and high school
it was kind of hard because i felt like
i had to include her in everything i did
um
just guess you needed that like extra
support
so yeah
so what what what what's happened
recently for that made you want to call
um well about five months ago i got
married
and
i have trouble feeling guilty like that
i'm not spending as much time with her
and also that it's kind of hard on my
mom to take care of her
um
are you feeling guilty are you feeling
grief
and here's the difference
guilt is this
is a violation of your personal
value system
um i did something that's against the
way i think it should have been done
or i cheated and i don't believe in
cheating i
hit somebody and i am a pacifist right
that's guilt
grief is the gap between what we wanted
or we hoped for we thought would happen
and what actually happened
and often folks who
love someone with special needs
who then transition to
basically like you're starting your own
life and your life has been on pause for
the last however many years because
whether you were told explicitly or you
felt it you've been living somebody
else's life
and yeah or you've been living two lives
at the same time or a life and a half or
whatever and now you're starting your
own and there's this grief this i can't
believe i missed my whole childhood
and not married i can't believe that
like there's nobody like no one's gonna
be able to take care does that make
sense so is it guilt or is it grief
um there's definitely some grief there
okay
um because sometimes i agree that like
i don't know it sounds bad but like i
didn't have a normal childhood so yeah
so let me free you of that
it can be both and
you can
have
really uh
you can be grateful for having been able
to serve your sibling with special needs
and serve your parents in a really
challenging situation growing up
and you can weep bitterly for having not
had a childhood
both of those are okay
and in fact you have to do both and or
one of the other ones will set your body
off
okay
you'll have trauma issues on either side
of that deal you have to own what
happened
and own the fact that
kids around you just got to like their
big concern was you know what tick-tock
dance did they know and what pair of
jeans they were going to wear and you
were busy
dealing with somebody with some some
very very unique needs right
and you're allowed to grieve that and
say that sucks and i wish it hadn't been
that way and boo hoo and
i love my sister i love her to death the
both of those are okay
okay okay and there's an entire industry
designed to make you feel multiple
industries to make you feel bad about
either way you think
of those on those issues right and it's
both and
um
so
what do boundaries look like moving
forward for you
i was actually going to ask you the best
way to set boundaries
because it's
yeah that's hard
i mean do you all live in the same
neighborhood
yeah we actually live in a renovated uh
trailer right now on my parents property
so that's been
a little tricky yeah i bet so um what's
your what's your
who are you married to
um
who am i married
tell me about the person you married
okay so we met at um a discipleship
school actually about three years ago
okay um and he's really great he um
he's like good at taking out my sister
and i together like he doesn't
he includes certain things um so have
you sat down with him and to discuss
what boundaries moving forward is going
to look like do you have a plan to get
out of the trailer and to get your own
place and to build your own life
um kind of right now it's
very at the beginning stages we're
saving up to hopefully move out
so we're not
in the same area as my parents like
yeah and when you say your mom can't
take care of your sister what does that
mean
well she can take care of her but it's
just really hard um
my parents marriage is like they're
still married but they're not they're
kind of like roommates so
it's been hard on her because she
doesn't get a lot of support
so grace what i'll tell you is
gonna be hard to hear okay
okay
those
your mom's marriage
your mom's parenting
your mom's this is hard and i'm
balancing things
those are her challenges to solve not
yours
yeah and the more you carry your mom's
challenges of her marriage of her
parenting of her whatever
into your new marriage you're coming
you're bringing excess weight into that
thing that your new marriage cannot
carry
you'll crash you'll crash the whole
thing
so kind of like i told you earlier it
can be both hand
you can really be sad for your mom
and that's her challenge to solve not
yours
think of it like you've heard me talk
about bricks in your backpack have you
ever heard me talk about that yeah i
have okay so imagine you're holding a
brick
that you're you're talking to your mom
and she's telling you about her marriage
and about this and oh my gosh i can't
believe it
and she just handed you that brick you
can hold it and you can look at it
that's what love is i'm gonna hold it
with you i'm gonna hold it for you for a
minute
and then i'm gonna hand it back to you
because i can't carry this
and sometimes for me handing it back
when i'm doing something hard is i'm
writing stuff down sometimes handing it
back there's all different ways to set
those down but
i'm not gonna carry that because i can't
do anything about it other than drown
myself trying to trying to save you
can't do anything about it okay so
repeat after me i can't fix my mom's
marriage
i can't fix my mom's marriage
and starting today
say it
i'm starting today i'm going to stop
trying
i'm going to stop trying
i can love my sister say it
i can love my sister
but i'm not her mom
but i'm not her mom there you go
so here's what i want you to do i want
you and your husband to go out
i don't want you all to dream real big
not in a cheesy way nothing like
but in a
in three years what would our life look
like
and then this is gonna be hard i want
y'all to reverse engineer that
what do we have to start doing today
this week this weekend next week next
month
so that this happens
and this dream may have a dollar amount
attached to it
this dream may have we're gonna have our
own place this dream may be we're going
to move to texas i don't i don't really
know what it's going to be
but we're going to reverse engineer it
and when it comes to your sister
it's going to be some reverse
engineering that will look like hey mom
we're going to have we're going to work
really hard to save up this much money
which means i gotta start working three
jobs over the next 12 to 18 months
so i'm not gonna be able to come pick up
sis
i'm just not gonna i'm not gonna have
the bandwidth to do it and so i'm
letting you know ahead of time i used to
i usually do these things
great hey sister we are gonna come up
with an every two
every two weeks
you and i are gonna go out together it's
gonna be our thing
what we're doing is we're gently setting
up boundaries so that your sister can
have a day to
plan
you can have a day to plan but you also
have 13 days off in between to have to
live your life because you've never had
to live your life right
yeah
and that's both a blessing and a curse
it's a blessing because you've been able
to pour into somebody else for so long
but i don't know that you know how
right so you're gonna have to practice
how to have your own life you're gonna
find yourself bored to death and when
you get bored you're gonna either do
you're gonna pick up your phone and
start scrolling or you're gonna try to
reinsert yourself back into mom's drama
yeah
you have to find new am i am i right
yeah so you got to find new coping
mechanisms you have to find new things
to get involved with and my hope is
those are going to be
taking care of you taking care of this
knucklehead new husband of yours taking
care of your new baby marriage right
um whatever that's going to look like
working towards those things that you
guys decided you all wanted to to work
towards
and
expect some pushback expect to feel
guilty expect lots of grief
all the time what do i do when i uh feel
guilty and grief like how do i handle it
write it down
write it down
i would have a guilty and grief journal
that's just yours and the magic of grief
is you have to have a witness you've got
to have somebody that you're talking to
so if that means you got to find a
counselor and you'll build that into
your budget then do that now
i would recommend
since you don't have a good picture of
what a healthy marriage looks like
you're kind of making this up as you go
and your parents didn't become roommates
overnight
it happened over time yeah they probably
were in love when they got together
that's my guess maybe not but that's my
guess
and
so roommateness
that's not really a diagnostic i should
make that up though roommateness happens
to the best of us it's happened to me it
happens to everybody and you've got to
intentionally lean out of it
or lean way way way into it
i would love to see you and your husband
go to counseling now while y'all are
healthy and why things are young and
while your marriage is new
and you all begin practicing language
that's going to be boundary language
love language desire language you're
going to learn some skills right now
that will pay off 20 30 40 years from
now
okay
and here's the word i want you to keep
in your head keep this in your head keep
this in your head practice
practice practice practice you're going
to practice boundaries you're going to
practice telling your sister not today
you're gonna practice not getting
involved there's gonna be times you call
your mom just at a habit and be like
hey how's dad and then you're gonna go
nope nope nope no no i'm stopping i'm
stopping i'm stopping i don't want to
know that's your husband
you're right you're practicing this
you're gonna start to pick up your cell
phone when you're bored
no put it down put it down you're gonna
practice it right
and then you're gonna think what's one
thing i could do to love my husband
right this second we're gonna do that
i'm gonna lean that way right so we're
gonna practice practice everything
moving forward is practicing
and like everyone in practice who wants
to get good at something you get a coach
i had was with a professional coach this
morning you're gonna find a coach that's
gonna help you and that's gonna be your
marriage counselor or some pastor that
you trust that's not a goofball
making stuff up
or whoever right so
man your sister is lucky to have you
lucky two have had you and you're not
going anywhere for a while your
husband's lucky to have you let's start
changing the family tree today